et cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
minh tran huy bonjour bonjour bienvenue
sur ce plateau vous êtes journalistes et
aux tris votre dernier texte est un
récit à la première personne un enfant
sans histoire qui vient de sortir chez
actes sud l'enfant du titre c'est le
vôtre votre fils aîné paul dit paulo qui
a presque neuf ans qui a 9 ans
précisément aujourd'hui c'est son
anniversaire
et bien voilà qui a 9 ans juste
aujourd'hui et qui est autiste fait
qu'est ce que ça veut dire être autiste
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour paul
c'est l'objet du livre
oui tout à fait en fait évidemment quand
il était tout petit on avait encore
aucune idée de ses problèmes de
communication en fait c'est très facile
de détecter un enfant autiste des
dix-huit mois s'il ne pointe pas du
doigt s'il ne regarde pas dans les yeux
s'il ne répond pas son prénom il ya un
problème
après lotissement lui-même en fait ça se
détecte pas comme pour je sais pas une
angine ou la rougeole
regardez comportement de l'enfant et
c'est en évaluant ces comportements
qu'on peut apprécier si les autistes ou
pas en l'occurrence c'est quand il a des
problèmes d'interaction de communication
et des centres d'intérêt restreint
répétitif des comportements répétitifs
sachant que les centres d'intérêts
restreint ça peut être regarder une
petite voiture et la faire rouler a
défini mais ça peut être aussi je sais
pas
l'astrophysique ce que dit ce livre
entre autres choses c'est qu'il ya
quasiment autant d'autisme que
d'autistes oui tout à fait puisque en
fait chacun de ses enfants à une
personnalité des traits de caractère une
sensorialité aussi différentes certains
par exemple sont extrêmement sensibles
au bruit d'autres sont sensibles à la
lumière d'autres ont des rituels
particulier pour manger je me rappelle
d'un enfant par exemple qui ne mangent
que ce qui est jaune donc c'est assez
compliqué mon jeu la banane ou
des grains de maïs mais voilà ils
mangent que ce qui est jaune paula
certain nombre aussi de rituels un
certain nombre de blocages s'évacue d'un
autisme sévère puisque l'autisme c'est
un spectre en fait donc sur ce spectre
il y a d'un côté on va dire ce qu'ils on
y vit très diminuée qui ne parlent pas
dont on ne sait pas s'ils pensent donc
ça ne sais pas comment ils pensent
qu'ils peuvent faire des crises en se
roulant par terre et on ne sait pas
pourquoi et de à l'autre bout du spectre
vous avez des personnes qui ont
simplement on va dire des difficultés
d'adaptation mais qui finissent par
réussir à s'adapter mais qui sont ce
qu'on appellerait bizarre socialement il
a fallu deux ans vous le disiez tout à
l'heure pour que votre enfant chez qui
vous vous saviez bien que quelque chose
clochait chez soi diagnostiqué
officiellement et encore vous devez
beaucoup à vous même oui en fait nous ce
qu'on a remarqué ce qu'ils répondaient
pas à son prénom quand même ça nous a
inquiétés on se dit c'est bizarre les
autres enfants ils répondent à leurs
prénoms donc on a demandé des examens
notre médecin il a vérifié l'audition de
paul trois fois hong kong a quand même
demandé trois fois et il n'a rien trouvé
et finalement c'est une amie avec qui on
était parti en vacances qui elle a eu
trois enfants ce pôle c'est vrai que
c'est notre premier renfort donc on
n'avait pas de point de comparaison et
au bout de deux semaines quand on est
rentré mon ami m'a appelé m'a dit écoute
je sais que tu as déjà consulté pour
palm et je pense qu'il faut que tu
consultes une nouvelle fois et
là du coup je me suis mise à faire des
recherches moi même évidemment prise
d'une angoisse sévère et j'ai trouvé que
quand un enfant pointe pas du doigt il
regardait pas dans les yeux et répondait
pas son prénom dans 90% des cas il était
autiste et du coup là on est allé chez
un autre médecin qui nous a dit en effet
ya un problème de développement
mais ensuite
j'ai eu une petite surprise c'est que
m'a envoyée dans l'ain cmpp donc un
centre medico pédo psychiatrique et
psychologique
qui s'occupe des enfants et adolescents
notamment pour donc pour les traiter et
on l'a on m'a dit alors en effet votre
votre enfant un problème mais ce qu'on
m'a dit ensuite m'a un peu surprise à
savoir
oui il serait à la mode aujourd'hui de
dire qu'il souffre de tsa donc de
troubles du spectre autistique dont déjà
le mot à la mode nous a paru un peu
étrange et ensuite mon arrêté avec moi
on lui a posé aucune question en
revanche on s'est tourné vers moi on m'a
un peu cuisiner sur ma famille mais s'il
ne partait pas une responsabilité dans
ce qui arrive est à votre fils nous a
dit que c'était d'origine étrangère et
que sûrement ça avait créé un trauma
chez mon fils parce que l'exil c'est
très dur à vie je puis au vietnam il ya
eu beaucoup de guerre et que sans doute
salées sont manifestement certaines
générations puisque comme vous le voyez
je suis peut-être autiste mais en tout
cas je parle mais que du coup mon enfant
ne parlait pas ses passagers est
sidérant effectivement à l'art au début
vous ne savez pas grand chose alors vous
vous documenter beaucoup et vous vous
dites qu'avec du temps pas mal de moyens
parce que ça coûte cher on va y revenir
avec les bons professionnels autour de
paul avec de la patience avec de l'amour
vous finirez par trouver la clé mais
vous finissez par dire que la clé vous
ne l'avez pas trouvé voir vous vous
demandez s'il y a vraiment une clé oui
en chemin en fait j'ai compliqué mais
pas forcément de serrure donc ne peut
pas trouver de clés c'est vrai que le en
fait quand l'enfant au départ à 3 ans en
fait un enfant autiste dit de haut
niveau qui parviendra à parler qui
parviendra à aller à l'école qui
parviendra à s'adapter
se différencie pas d'un enfant autiste
raluy autistes sévère la seule chose qui
peut nous le dire c'est pas les
professionnels aucun des professionnels
ne se risque plus à faire des paris sur
l'évolution d'un enfant c'est le temps
en fait ce qui est certain c'est qu'une
prise en charge adaptée elle est où les
enfants quoi qu'il arrive de ceux qui
sont atteints d'autisme sévère comme
ceux qui sont atteints d'autisme plus
léger et on le voit avec paul il a
appris par exemple la propreté moi je
connais sinon des enfants qui m'attend
sont adultes ils ont 20 ans ils sont
trente ans ils ont 40 ans ils sont pas
propres vols il a pu la prendre en fait
les tous les enfants sont capables
d'apprendre simplement dans le cas de
paul c'est beaucoup plus long puisque
son âge mental et 18 mois en fait vous
écrivez que paul ne possédera jamais de
mots qui n'aura ni scolarité ni carrière
ni camarades ni compagne ni descendance
vous parlez de l'amour si douloureux que
vous avez pour lui comment est ce qu'on
fait face en tant que maman je pense
qu'il n'y a pas vraiment de recette en
vérité
vous vous envoie comme ça un gros
fardeau à porter on apprend à le porter
parce que c'est votre enfant moi je
pense que dans cette histoire ce qui
était très important c'était l'amour de
mon mari de son soutien parce que en
fait 85 % des enfants enfin des parents
d'enfants autistes divorce il ne
supporte pas fait les preuves que c'est
pour imaginer qu'on ne dort plus il ya
deux jours quand on s'est réveillé donc
paul n'avait pas dormi mais il avait
aussi maculé les murs et les sols et les
tapis de ses excréments donc on apprend
à vivre avec ces épreuves là et
effectivement c'est très dur de voir son
enfant se rouler par terre disons mais
pourquoi il souffre on sait pas comment
et pourquoi et souffre ce qu'il a et on
est tout le temps des charlots cost en
train de rechercher en tas de son ventre
on tâte son front est ce qu il a chaud
et ce qu'il a mal au ventre peut pas
nous le dire il est même pas capable de
nous montrer son nez si on le lui
demande donc à partir de là chaque jour
est un combat mais bombe très vite on
s'aperçoit que c'est un marathon et que
c'est pas un sprint donc on apprend à
économiser son énergie on prend des
antidépresseurs aussi à ses affaires
chez calmement vous avait espéré
longtemps que votre fille soit une
exception ces autistes dont on vante les
aptitudes prodigieuse ou les parcours
extraordinaire
c'est le cas de la femme dont le
portrait répond comme en écho à celui de
votre fils elle est américaine à la 75
ans elle s'appelle tumble gardine je
crois qu'on va voir une photo d'elle
dites nous pourquoi vous avez voulu
raconter son histoire
et bien en fait quand donc moi dans la
vie je suis écrivain et comme beaucoup
d'écrivains je m'arrache m'intéresse à
ce qui n'est pas racontée à ce qui est
mis sous le tapis donc j'aime raconter
l'irracontable ce qui est caché ce qui
n'a pas été transmis ce qui a été oublié
et tous mes livres précédents entre
était déjà mais sous forme de roman est
là à partir du moment où j'ai compris
qu'avec paul en fait on aller on avait
perdu on réussirait pas à la mener sur
le chemin de le faire rejoindre le pays
de la normalité si je puis dire là est
apparu le désir peut-être d'en faire un
livre puisque justement pas l'été une
énigme comment est ce qu'on raconte un
personnage qui n'évolue pas comment on
raconte parce que toutes les histoires
que ce soit au cinéma en littérature que
sur à l'oral se racontent l'évolution
d'un personnage qui va d'un point à un
point z qui a subi des épreuves qui j'en
sors transformé qui devient un héros bon
au mauvais mais ça à eruh paul il marche
pas comme ça paul il n'a pas d'évolution
au sens strict du terme il ya de
l'action mais n'y a pas d'évolution et à
partir de ce moment là je me suis dit
m'a peut-être que la meilleure façon de
raconter paul c'est de raconter ce lieu
plutôt celle qui n'est pas à savoir
tempel grand deane qui elle est aussi
autiste qui est parti du même point que
lui donc elle maculaient osciller ces
murs d'excréments elle était une petite
irascible incontrôlable qu'on ne
comprenait pas avec ne pouvait pas
communiquer qu'on ne pouvait pas serrer
dans ses bras et grâce à sa mère et
grâce en fait une prise en charge qui
ressemble énormément à celle de paul
c'est une famille qui avait des moyens
c'était une mère intelligente qui
employait une gouvernante à temps plein
qui à dire tiens tu peux être que je
peut stimuler cet enfant en lui
proposant ceci ou cela je vais lui
apprendre le tour de roger lui apprendre
ceci cela d'apple grand deane elle est
allée à l'école elle a parlé bien sûr
elle est allée au lycée elle est allée à
l'université elle est devenue une
sommité finalement dans son domaine
c'est celui de l'industrie d'élevage
à savoir que halo dans les années 70 il
faut imaginer en plus une femme est en
plus une femme handicapée qui réussi à
expliquer aux grands pontes de
l'industrie d'élevage bah vous savez
vous avez pas besoin de frapper les
bêtes pour qu'elles avancent n'avait pas
besoin de les stresser au moment où vous
allez les abattre on peut trouver des
moyens grâce à au design pour que elle
circule tranquillement et qu'elle ne
marque plus d'arrêts est devenu aussi
une grande voix pour pour les autistes
mal à les autistes par mois elle a
raconté son son parcours ce que sont ce
que sa vie raconte aussi au rappel et
vous le disais c'est que la condition
sociale est un facteur déterminant se
livrent en ce sens est très politique la
france est incroyablement en retard tant
sur le diagnostic on en parlait tout à
l'heure que sur la prise en charge en
passant par la scolarisation sa
scolarisation sachant qu'il ya
aujourd'hui en france 700 milles
audistes oui en fait la france a été
condamné cinq fois par le conseil de
l'europe pour discrimination vis-à-vis
des autistes mais bon en fait à chaque
fois que je raconte ça tout le monde
ouvre de grands yeux et en fait on
s'aperçoit que alors que compte 700
milles autiste a priori 350 milles qui
comme quoi elle ne parleront jamais ça
représente quand même une proportion
significative de la population est
effectivement ou manquent de tout on n'a
pas de personnel formé les médecins même
ne sont pas formés les enseignants ne
sont pas formés il n'y a pas de
structures d'accueil il n'y a pas de
possibilités d'évolution pour les
autistes il existe des structures
d'accueil où c'est plus ou moins du
gardiennage en fait parce qu'encore une
fois les gens ne sont pas formés c'est
pas si dur de former les gens nous on a
des baby-sitters on en a 20 ans et à
chaque fois on les a formés on l'a dit
voilà comment on peut réagir avec paul
voilà comment on peut interagir avec
paul voilà comment est ce que vous
pouvez communiquer avec lui avec des
images puisqu'il existe un système de
communication par image il est très très
peu ampoulé en france et on comprend pas
c'est vraiment des questions de bon sens
pourquoi la france qui a un retard mais
le retard ça se comble et la sas comble
pas il manque d dizaines de milliers de
places pour les adultes comme pour les
enfants c'est la question que pose en
partie ce récit merci infiniment à minh
tran huy d'être venu nous en parlait ce
matin on a une pensée pour paul donc
dont c'est le neuvième anniversaire
aujourd'hui ni tout à fait et pour son
petit frère serge qui a derrière deux
ans merci on pas autiste merci encore
merci à un enfant sans histoire dont qui
vient de sortir chez actes sud un livre
bouleversant très politique on le disait
merci encore infiniment